the marvel cinematic universe needs
loki the god butcher and here's the
reason why we're going to talk a little
bit slower too apparently i've been
talking too fast recently for you guys
it's been throwing you guys off
but here's the thing loki in the marvel
cinematic universe is a very
toned down version of his character and
anybody who's been reading marvel comics
for any measure of time will tell you
that
loki's had some crazy schemes in the
past in marvel comics there was a time
where he incited a war between the
avengers and the defenders the defenders
were cool they were an interesting team
those guys who don't know a little bit
of history here a little bit comic book
history here the defenders were almost
like an extension of the avengers but
not really it initially started off as
an unfinished doctor strange story by
roy thomas and he wanted to finish it
out so he finished it in the incredible
hulk and in namor the submariner but
fans love seeing doctor strange
crossover with these characters so
marvel eventually featured a team up
between these three characters in a
story called marvel feature back in the
day and this basically led to
fans loving it so marvel said okay let's
just create the defenders they gave him
their own solo series and it was huge
ran for like 125 issues eventually
marvel canceled it and then what they
followed up with was something called
the new defenders which got cancelled
and then there was actually a group
called the secret defenders which was
amazing and i would love to see them in
the mcu we might make a video on that if
you guys care anything about this kind
of stuff but the secret defenders is
kind of a quick little
explanation was basically a story or a
series of stories where doctor strange
would grab like
wolverine and spider-man carol danvers
and like captain america
and they would go and fight dormammu or
something like that it was a different
roster in every single story and it was
an awesome concept
terribly executed but it was an awesome
concept but back on track
loki and the mcu loki's had some pretty
crazy stories in comics right there was
a story called acts of vengeance where
he actually grabbed
all the different villains at least the
major villains anyway and had them face
off against heroes that they would
normally
never face off against and they almost
conquered the world there was a story
called the asgardian wars where loki
actually incited a conflict between the
asgardians and the
x-men which was amazing but he's done
all kinds of crazy things
loki the god butcher is probably the
most interesting
and really the most hyper violent
version of loki he's largely based off a
character or version of loki that
actually wiped out all life on earth
technically the way he explains it
humanity was already doing it anyway
with like you know overpopulation and
environmental problems stuff like that
but he basically
ended up killing off all the superheroes
and then humanity just more or less sort
of dwindled after that at least those
who didn't obliterate anyway but the
whole idea behind this is it's
predicated on a character called for the
god butcher now you guys know gore the
god butcher is going to be in
thor love and thunder so kind of a brief
little explanation here at least as
brief as you can make when it comes to
gore
gore was basically a guy who cursed the
gods and the whole idea behind this is
that he lived among
a nomadic tribe more or less on just
this really crappy world where like
nothing ever grew and life was awful
it was terrible it was like moses right
just like just it was just rough right
just walk in the desert for eons well
the whole thing behind this is that
during that time
his wife and his kid died and so because
his tribe always prayed to the gods
under the belief
that gods would provide them with like
rain fauna or flora so they could thrive
and grow
and eat for a time that never really
seemed to happen and so gore came to the
belief that the gods had basically
abandoned him he believed they were real
but he believed they just didn't care
about his race or really anybody in
general so because he cursed the gods he
was kicked out of his tribe eventually
he comes across the body of a guy named
null
and just some other unnamed god now as a
quick aside here null was actually a god
or kind of
being who existed before all creation so
he's more of like a primordial life
force but basically the way this played
out when the celestials were like
creating life across the universe which
led to the eternals that they pissed off
null because null liked the idea of just
emptiness right he was like the ultimate
anti-social person he just wanted to be
left alone like leave my universe alone
and what ended up happening here is a
fight ensued between null
and the celestials nil created something
called the all-black necro sword
and then killed one of the celestials by
cutting his head off so that giant
celestial head that floats in space and
is used
as basically nowhere that kind of giant
space station everybody hangs out
that's the head of the celestial that
null killed that's why a lot of people
who saw the celestial head
in the marvel cinematic universe and
then later on saw null in marvel comics
thought the two were connected and that
we're gonna see null in the marvel
cinematic universe
i don't know if we really will or not
but noah was the one who created like
the the symbiotes like venom and all
that kind of stuff or at least
created the race that eventually led to
venom the important thing here is that
the all black necro sword of null
was laying on this planet alongside that
god so gore picked it up
and then gore became gore the god
butcher and so he literally
spent like all this time traveling
across the universe and just like
countless ages
killing all these different gods he
could come across right like he
tortured the god of torture like it was
crazy man
it was it was amazing it was one of the
coolest stories ever right thor god of
thunder is where it's at with jason
aaron but it was it was one of the
craziest things
like there comes a point in the comics
when gore is basically defeated by three
versions of thor from three different
time periods it's like the craziest
thing
ever right like thor has like two
mjolnirs and the all black sword he
takes it takes his hammers like
smacks them together and it's like the
craziest thing but ultimately
gore is defeated right now there's a
future point in time where he comes back
but before he did
loki found the all black necro sword and
then he became
loki the all butcher here's the crazy
thing in this future point in time again
he's based off the version of loki that
wiped out all life on earth so earth is
just like a barren place like a barren
wasteland where like nothing really
grows
and then you had asgard where old king
thor just dwelled with like his
daughters or
his granddaughters or whoever they were
but the important thing here is that the
fight between
loki the all butcher and old king thor
was
crazy they ended up fighting initially
on asgard and just
raised the world right like just trashed
the entirety of asgard and then like
their fight like blinks out the sun
like one of the things that that loki
did when he first got the all black
necro sword he killed
ego the living planet like it was nuts
it's a super
short moment right it only lasts two
issues or a issue or something like that
it's not a lengthy thing at all
ultimately he's killed by gore who
actually returns so it's one of the one
of the crazy moments there but having
that version of loki in the marvel
cinematic universe can you imagine that
because the only significant thing that
loki's really done up to this point
was like lead an invasion in new york
right like an alien invasion on earth
that's business as usual in marvel
comics there are stories that
open with that happening right like the
story opens up like the avengers are
just fighting some enemy somewhere some
alien invasion they're like yeah it's
like a tuesday
and like the story picks up after the
aliens are defeated that's just normal
stuff right that's nothing special it
was cool in the context of the movie
but in the grand scheme of the things
that loki's done that's absolutely
nothing
and i would love to see like all butcher
or or loki the god butcher
in the mcu i would love to see that just
dark twisted just just killed all life
on earth he's got a sword that lets him
kill celestial gods
and it can be one of those things where
like it's like a future version of
himself you don't see a whole lot of it
right you just see him in a loki and
loki tv show and you get like
maybe half an episode or like a few
moments of focus on him and it's just
like yeah this is a version of yourself
that killed like
all the eternals and killed like all the
avengers
people will appear with magic genes that
give them powers at some point in time
and like
you killed all of them and like you
killed the celestials
it's just you killed all these things
and did all this stuff
and now you just rule as like some
omnipotent god with like a sword
made of like a living abyss like that'd
be cool man like i would love to i would
love to see that but like
it's stuff like this that gets me
excited man like the possibilities of
the mcu that's what gets me excited
because in the end
it's all based on comics i mean sure
like kevin feige came out recently and
said like they are delving in the idea
of just creating stories on their own
that have never happened in comics which
i think is awesome it creates a cool
concept right i'm
not going to see a repeat of a story
that i've seen before but i do love the
idea of them taking characters like that
and there's a lot of things that i want
to see and i'm almost cinematic universe
let me know if you guys are interested
in this kind of thing right like i want
to see the defenders in the mcu so like
the incredible hulk silver surfer doctor
strange and name with a submariner
teaming up
facing off against threats like i want
to see old man logan done the right way
i want to see characters like blue
marvel
adam brashear i want to see this kind of
stuff in the mcu let me know if you guys
are interested in seeing more videos
like this and i will catch you all later
peace